what the [ __ ] why okay i love [ __ ]
gears of war why is it on your list
okay so i i had a hard choice putting
mike my not
yeah my last three um so gears of war is
on there
because it is the first multiplayer game
that's
it was the game that is on there because
that's how
i discovered online gaming and i'm just
like
matt gears of war was a good [ __ ]
online game no dude it was clean
yeah and honestly gears of war 2 was
really the first game where i was like
whoa video games can like make me sad
wait what oh the story stories okay no i
didn't give a [ __ ] about the story the
story's so
good i don't even think i finished that
why am i what are we swapping
bro this story is so good i literally
put this on here because
like i had such a hard time because i'm
just like i didn't give a [ __ ] about the
story i didn't want to do
this one thing i remember about gizzle
it's the story the story is so
i remember this again it doesn't count
as spoilers anymore it's so [ __ ] old
yeah what's the story again um the
locusts are taking over the earth and
they're basically stopping them etcetera
etcetera
i mean that's basically like their wow
no no
because there was like the the the two
duo who you're following which is uh
i just remember one guy trying to look
for his wife that was the sad part
and then he like finds it but then he
didn't find it it was like an illusion
and then i'm like what the [ __ ]
i was like i was like 13. i'm like i'm
like what this is
this [ __ ] massive lead hit of a
character just like breaks down in the
battlefield
i'm just like oh my god i was just like
this is the first game when i'm just
like oh chainsaw
that's how it gets you in right so giza
will get you in with the chainsaw go
bruh super manly man and then 10 minutes
in you're [ __ ] crying and you're like
whoa what's happening
the one memory i hold for gears of war
two the multiplayer
is just the sound you the sound it makes
when you pop a guy's head off with a
sniper
okay like i uh like yeah i played two
yeah
like that was i think that soul sound
and i don't know why it was so
[ __ ] satisfying because it was it was
like literally cracking an egg well i
mean those
those those shotguns are like still
there's like no multiplayer experience
like the online and gears of war
it's just shotguns yeah yeah like that's
like the meta it's like you have to run
up to people and shotgun each other
right right
okay the shotgun was also really
satisfying when you got like a point
blank and
the body just explodes my god like
like you're the monkey brain but that
was like the first time i'm just like
okay i i i enjoy this now this is fun uh
it was really sexy i think uh gears of
war got plagued by the fact that there
was just like a
like uh there'd always be like uh two
really [ __ ] god tier players
in the game that could just dominate the
whole lobby yeah so it just kind of
became
not fun after a while if you weren't
like a pro yeah you just get [ __ ]
destroyed by the like good players i def
i didn't play on
i didn't play online gears of war 2 a
lot because like i didn't know what
console was it on again three years
because i didn't own a 360 because
yeah i played at my friend's place a lot
just like lan multiplayer and that was
like really really fun but yeah
yeah i probably from the sounds of it i
probably wouldn't enjoy it both online
no you you probably wouldn't now i mean
it was me discovering
what multiplayer meant and before i
started hating okay
gears of war started my love for
multiplayer games league of legends
killed it
okay league of legends is in the middle
because i think out of
out of all these games i have probably
played league of legends the most
right not proud to admit it um but the
reason it's on there is because i think
the honeymoon period of league of
legends for me was probably
the best gaming experience of my life it
was really long for me as well
i'm just like like two years long that's
a long honeymoon
dude when you get into that game and
it's going well it feels so fun yeah
that's great
it's so fun to get into it's just it's
hard yeah because the problem is now i
feel like
multiplayer games just aren't fun unless
you are getting into it
immediately as it's released right
because the problem the problem with
multiplayer games i found now
is that you have a new game and that's
when a new game just gets released
that's the fun part because nobody
nobody really knows how to be good at
the game
everyone's just kind of like really
discovering what works and what doesn't
everyone's just [ __ ] having fun yeah
and then you get to a point in
multiplayer
where people just realize how to
optimize the fun out of the game the
sweaty boys
that's what happened with like fortnight
honestly like honestly like
me all memes aside fortnight was so fun
when it first came out yeah
it blew up and then when i got to the
point where everyone would like build a
[ __ ] mortgage right in front of your
eyes within 10 seconds and you couldn't
do anything it's like well this is just
not fun anymore
i don't have the dexterity of like a
chimp on on like coke right like
how am i supposed to do this yeah
because i remember like i really really
[ __ ] enjoyed overwatch when it first
came out yeah me too like i
i didn't make the same mistake of trying
to do ranked um because because i'd
learned from league of legends but even
just playing casually i really really
[ __ ] enjoyed it
and then they got to a point when even
in casual games
you weren't allowed to have fun anymore
you got this the same the same
uh the same heroes change of hands
i mean i i would fully admit i was like
a genji main because i was a dirty leaf
and the reason i played genji was
because i [ __ ] sucked at genji
but like the one the one time out of ten
where i i did an alt and it actually
worked out that was the reason i played
genji
like nine out of ten times i would
completely flunk it i would fail i would
get killed straight away
but that one time that one time when it
worked out i that that that's what i
lived for man
and because of that i was one of the
most talked i was i wasn't the most
toxic ones but i was
i was that one genji on your team that
probably threw you the magic i was that
i was that person did you talk [ __ ] to
your teammates i didn't talk
i'm not a toxic gamer funnily enough i'm
just like oh come on guys we can do it
if we are
all put together
we can win with the power of friendship
come on guys oh my god
and ranked you had to get to start like
shouting at people get them to shut up
i'm just like i'm just like that guy who
just goes mutual and just does my own
thing
yeah i do that sometimes too i mean i i
play it as closely as
a single player game as i can because um
like playing online game just makes me
makes you realize how [ __ ] how much i
hate people
people are the worst especially in
competitive ones right that's why like
but in japan it's so weird because like
people just don't smack talk
at all they don't know how to yeah it's
and most you'll get passive aggression
yeah like i'd probably i'd probably
enjoy
japanese compared to the game no one
talks unless you talk to them
because i play in the league servers in
japan and like 90 of them are just
chinese smurfs
so of course they're like toxic as [ __ ]
you know yeah that's why i don't really
play anymore because it's just like you
can't [ __ ] have fun in league of
legends
it's just like a korean chinese
playground but they're like oh let's go
and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] with the japanese players who
are suck at this game yeah it's it's
literally just
it's literally just the playground where
the school bullies go to to just like
bully like this
lebron james coming down to the
elementary match
[Laughter]
you feel like you suck